- You Jack?
- Yeah.
How you doing?
- How you doing?
- Good.
I'm Frank
Hello, Frank,
nice to meet you.
Dani said this is
generational, huh?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Fourth gen?
Fourth generation.
1946, that's when my
great-grandfather and
grandfather went into business.
My father took over
the business in 1970,
and I took over the
business in 1990.
FRANK: How many
acres you got here?
40 acres.
FRANK: 40 acres?
You guys gotta clean the
property up, or something?
Well, yeah.
Things are moving here.
There's a big housing
development going next door.
The whole area is changing.
You know, people in new
houses aren't gonna wanna
see all this junk around here.
And I really don't want my
family to have to clean this up
if something happens to me.
I want to have it all
neat and tidy now.
My grandfather just loved Mack
Trucks, the old chain drives.
MIKE: Yeah.
Mack Truck was
just something he
always really
endeared and loved,
so I have several of them.
My grandfather and
great-grandfather
couldn't afford a Mack Truck.
Mack Truck was top of the line.
They always dreamed of
having a Mack Truck.
So basically, we have a lot
of trucks and everything,
but mostly we like Macks.
How many you got?
Well, now we're
down to about 35,
but the collection, at one
time, was up to about 300.
You're down to 35?
- Yeah, we're down to 35.
- 300?
Yeah.
Collecting of the
antique Mack Trucks
didn't happen till
probably the late 70s.
It was my grandfather
that actually
bought the first antique truck.
Then my father and I
started buying them,
and it was just-- my father
would go across the country,
from here to California,
buying Mack Trucks.
My dad and I would go out to
people's places of business,
houses, wherever,
and buy memorabilia,
tractors, trucks, or what
have you, and bring it home.
He had the sickness, huh?
He had the sickness.
That's the way I
am with motorcycles.
We did it week,
after week, after week.
Do you have anything
in these containers?
Well, there's nothing
really in these containers,
they're pretty much empty.
But I've got some trailers
that have some stuff in them
that we can go look at.
Ha, yeah.
So Frank and I crawl
inside of a trailer
that the roof has caved in on.
If we're gonna find
something in this place,
we're gonna have to dig.
Underneath it, over
it, crawl through it.
These are the kind of
picks that we love.
That's cool.
An old oil sand table.
- Yeah.
It was a motor display
table, more or less.
Different tiered display table.
I had forgotten it was there.
MIKE: 100% pure paraffine.
JACK: Amoco.
MIKE: Yeah, the legs are bent,
and they're twisted, and stuff.
But that can be heated up,
and it can be straightened.
The porcelain is
really in good shape.
Both sides porcelain, nice.
This one's actually
the worse of the two.
JACK: Yeah.
MIKE: This big chip.
Want me to make
you an offer on it?
JACK: Yup.
MIKE: $350.
- That's fair.
- We doing it?
All right, cool.
MIKE: Who knew that
this thing was in here?
Even Jack forgot it
was in here, because it
was buried under so much stuff.
And that's the kind of
pick you want to be on.
What's that rocket
thing back there?
- Old gumball machine.
- Let me see that.
Let's go back there.
In the very back, I could
see this rocket ship.
And I think I know what
it is, but I'm not sure.
FRANK: Oh, yeah.
MIKE: Look at that, Frankie.
It's exactly what I
thought it was going to be.
I'll tell you what,
the guy that designed
this was absolutely brilliant.
He wanted to attract a
child to come up to it,
to be fascinated by it,
bum a quarter from his mom,
and hit this sucker.
All the color of the gumballs,
all the different colors
would have been
here, on display.
And then you've got
blue, white, red.
[music playing]
What a great piece.
Yeah, I've seen them for
sale a lot of different places,
when restored, to go
for $1,000, $1,200.
MIKE: Really?
JACK: Oh yeah, they're--
they're big dollars.
MIKE: No kidding.
I haven't seen one restored.
Yeah, it's rusty, it's
dirty, it's faded.
I mean, what are you
thinking on this?
Probably around $200.
MIKE: But it still draws you in.
All right, I'm gonna do it.
It's cool.